العقيد، كيف تستغل أوكرانيا هذه
الفوضى الآن،
حسنًا، هناك العديد من الأشياء التي يمكنهم
القيام بها أليسون وكما ذكر ديفيد، هناك
الكثير من الأشياء التي يمكن للأوكرانيين
النظر إليها بالفعل هنا، أحد الأشياء التي
أعتقد أنهم سيفعلونها ربما هو
ملاحقة مصلحتهم
ميزتهم التكتيكية في باكموت على سبيل المثال والتي
ستكون نقطة توكيل رئيسية
محتملة بالنسبة للأوكرانيين
شيء آخر يمكنهم فعله هو مع
انسحاب القوات الروسية من المحتمل
للدفاع ضد مجموعة فاغنر أه
يمكنهم ردم تلك المنطقة والاستيلاء على
مناطق الروس  تم التخلي عنها إذا حدث
ذلك، لا نعرف ما إذا كان ذلك
سيحدث أم لا، ولكن هذه هي
الأشياء التي
سيبحث عنها الأوكرانيون وأنا متأكد من أنهم
ربما سيستفيدون منها
بأسرع ما يمكن